Bonjour à tous. Aujourd'hui on va faire
un point et un bilan général sur la
fameuse tablette
dont on a beaucoup parlé. Tablette
d'ailleurs je sais même pas si on peut
parler de tablette tellement cet outil
à de nombreuses fonctionnalités à savoir la Yogabook de Lenovo.
Je vous l'avais expliqué il y a quelques
temps, j'ai eu la chance d'être
sélectionné par Lenovo
pour être l'un des 50 testeurs
officiels de la Yogabook. On a eu un
programme durant tout l'été, à partir
du mois de juin jusqu'à fin août. Je suis effectivement un petit peu
en retard, j'en suis désolé, pour
vous parler de cette Yogabook,
vous la présenter, vous expliquer
les différentes fonctionnalités, vous
montrer ce que l'on peut faire avec et cela
bien sûr en toute objectivité.
Bien évidemment on n'a aucune contrainte et
aucune obligation de la part de Lenovo
si ce n'est d'être loyal dans
nos propos. Donc tout ce que j'ai dit et
tout ce que je continue à dire sur
cette tablette, sur cet ordinateur est
complètement loyal. Pour ceux qui ne me
connaissent pas je suis Monsieur GRrr.
Je parle de stratégies Youtube sur ma chaîne mais
également des produits d'influence, des
produits qui nous aident à réussir
dans votre vie digitale.
D'ailleurs si vous voulez avoir toujours plus
d'informations sur votre stratégie ou
sur les produits digitaux
je vous invite à vous abonner à la
chaîne et à activer la cloche pour ne
manquer aucune publication.
On va faire un tour de cette Yogabook.
Pour vous la présenter très rapidement
la Yogabook c'est quoi ? La Yogabook c'est un book, un petit
bouquin. Vous ouvrez votre tablette vous
avez d'une part un écran, de l'autre
une zone qui est soit un clavier soit une
tablette graphique pour pouvoir dessiner
dessus. Vous pouvez l'utiliser en
ordinateur. Vous pouvez l'utiliser avec
cette partie qui est aimantée pour
pouvoir dessiner dessus et prendre des
notes. Comme vous pouvez le voir je
fais des dessins avec mon fils. Je ne
suis pas graphiste donc les dessins sont
quelques peu rudimentaires.
Vous pouvez aussi la replier pour
la poser sur un support et l'utiliser
pour visionner des films, faire ce que vous voulez, l'utiliser comme une tablette.
la refermer pour la tenir à votre main
comme une tablette. C'est vraiment
quelque chose qui est très pratique, qui
a plein de fonctionnalités.
La particularité de cette Yogabook de Lenovo est le mode tablette graphique.
Vous avez ce petit carnet qui est aimanté.
Regardez les jolis dessins. Mon fils de bientôt quatre ans c'est vraiment bien amusé avec.
Vous le posez ici, c'est aimanté.
Grâce à votre stylo la tablette
va reconnaître tous vos mouvements
et vous verrez vos dessins, vos
prises de notes s'afficher directement
sur l'écran.
Est-ce que cette Yogabook de
Lenovo est intéressante ?
Oui ou non ? Je vais vous dire ce que j'en ai pensé. Mon avis est très
subjectif parce que, d'une part je ne suis pas graphiste
donc je n'ai pas pu apprécier entièrement les qualités techniques de ce produit en ce qui concerne
les dessins, la tablette graphique.
Je l'ai utilisé surtout pour faire du
traitement de texte,
faire des recherches sur Internet, naviguer,
regarder des séries, regarder des
vidéos sur Youtube ...
De ce point de vue
là elle est très pratique.
L'écran est plutôt agréable. Si l'on
compare avec une autre tablette.
Je compare avec un iPad. Il faut
comparer ce qui est comparable
mais on constate que son écran est de bonne qualité. Autre intérêt : elle est
très fine. L'affichage est sympa, l'écran
est d'une bonne qualité. Je n'ai aucun reproche à lui faire.
Vous le mettez comme ça. Vous le mettez à la verticale.
Vous le mettez à l'horizontale. Vous en
faites sensiblement ce que vous voulez.
C'est vraiment très pratique. Je ne vais pas parler de l'utilisation de la tablette graphique
parce que dans ma famille nous sommes pas des artistes.
Mais bien évidemment je l'ai quand même essayée.
La prise de notes lorsque vous écrivez
est extrêmement bluffante.
L'écriture est reconnue. Les zones d'écritures sont bien délimitées.
Le Real Pen fonctionne très
bien. Vous avez la possibilité
d'avoir une mine avec de
l'encre ou alors d'avoir une mine
en gomme qui vous
permettra de dessiner directement sur la
tablette graphique sans risque
de l'endommager. Ca fonctionne,
c'est vraiment très bien. La seule chose
que je reproche à cette tablette
c'est la taille de son clavier.
Le principal problème que vous allez
rencontrer avec le clavier c'est
qu'il faut s'y habituer.
Ce n'est pas évident. Personnellement
j'utilise habituellement un Macbook Pro
donc je suis habitué à son clavier.
Sur la Yogabook tout est plus serré,
plus petit, j'ai eu du mal à m'y habituer. Cela ne veut pas dire que l'on ne peut pas s'y habituer.
Je n'ai pas des mains très grandes ni de très gros doigts
mais j'imagine que
quelqu'un qui aura des doigts un peu
plus gros que moi risque de rencontrer des difficultés. C'est pour moi le
point négatif de ce produit. Par contre
c'est très positif d'avoir
deux caméras. C'est idéal pour discuter  sur Whats App ...
Vous avez ici une petite caméra et vous en
avez une autre en haut juste ici.
Il existe deux versions : une
version Android et une version Windows 10.
Pour ma part j'ai reçu la
version Windows 10. Elle me convient
car je n'ai pas de PC donc ça me
permet d'avoir un petit pc portable.
C'est un deuxième ordinateur. Je dois reconnaître que
c'est pratique parce
certaines applications qui ne
fonctionnent pas sous Mac.
Je l'ai utilisée en déplacement,
on est parti cet été
en vacances en Sardaigne. D'ailleurs si
ça vous intéresse
j'ai fait une
petite vidéo très sympa ici.
Je l'ai utilisé. Ca m'a permis d'avoir
un outil de travail très compact,
facile à prendre en main, facile
à mettre dans mes bagages, qui ne pèse
pas très lourd.
Pour faire un bilan global
un bilan général de ce produit je dois
reconnaître que je suis plutôt
impressionné par plusieurs choses. Par
le format qui est très compact,
le format poche : vous la prenez, vous la glissez
dans une sacoche et elle vous suit partout.
Je ne suis pas graphiste mais j'ose
imaginer que pour des amis graphiste qui
veut le prendre des notes rapidement,
vous emmenez ça avec vous, avec le Real Pen, vous avez toujours quelque chose
sous la main pour griffonner, pour faire
un croquis, ou pour prendre des notes.
C'est pratique, c'est rapide.
Ca marche bien.
Ca répond bien
donc c'est très positif.
C'est un outil
qui va aussi bien convenir pour une
utilisation professionnelle que
familial. Autre point négatif sur
ce produit : c'est sa fragilité. Je ne suis pas quelqu'un
d'extrêmement bien soigneux mais je ne suis
pas non plus un barbare. J'ai la mauvaise
surprise de constater qu'il se
raillait  assez facilement. Je ne sais
pas si on le voit bien mais il est un
petit peu rayé.
J'ai eu également quelques rayures à l'arrière.
Je ne sais pas si on les voit bien
avec le contraste.
C'est l'un des points négatifs de ce produit.
Par contre le système
d'ouverture est bien conçu.
Elle est robuste.
Le produit a vraiment l'air solide.
Il y une vraie résistance à l'ouverture.
Elle est solide.
Vous pouvez brancher
ici un casque. Vous avez la possibilité
de brancher du HDMI. Vous pouvez
brancher un Micro USB.
Je donne un avis très favorable.
Je ne sais pas si
je serais allé l'acheter en magasin car je
n'en avais pas le besoin,
mais je suis très heureux d'avoir pu la découvrir
parce que c'est vraiment
le genre de produit dont je serais
passé à côté.
N'étant pas graphiste,
je n'aurais jamais utilisé cet outil.
Mais au final je suis assez content.
Je le trouve bien.
Très beau, très pratique.
Voila mon bilan général, mon
bilan de fin de test sur cette Yogabook de
Lenovo. Je tiens à vous le dire une fois de
plus mais je ne suis pas payé par
Lenovo. Je n'ai aucune obligation de parole.
Si vous avez une Yogabook,
dites-moi ce que vous en pensez ?
Quelles sont vos impressions par rapport
à cette phase de test ?
Trouvez-vous ce produit intéressant ?
Oui ? Non ?
Envisageriez-vous de l'acquérir ?
Dessinez-vous ? Êtes-vous graphiste ?
Avez-vous un talent d'illustrateur ?
Si c'est le cas pensez-vous que cet outil
peut vous rendre service ?
Et dans le cas contraire dites-moi ce
que vous utilisez ? J'ai hâte de lire
vos commentaires. Je vous remercie
beaucoup d'abord regarder cette vidéo
je vous invite à vous abonner à
ma chaîne parce qu'il y aura encore plus de vidéos
pour réussir sur Youtube et pour découvrir
tous les produits qui vous aideront à
réussir sur Youtube.
Quant à moi je vous dis à très
bientôt. Si vous avez des questions vous
pouvez aussi me suivre sur Twitter
@MonsieurGRrr et poser vos questions
avec le hashtag #MonsieurGRrr.
Je vous dis à très bientôt
et d'ici là portez-vous bien.
Ciao ciao.